-Congratulations on your book
being the "New York Times"
best-seller.
So, you wrote about 1950s
Washington, D.C.
This is a thriller.
This is about politicians.
This is about the swamp
and corruption.
I would have thought
that if you wrote a book,
you would maybe try to
escape from what you
talk about every day.
But it seemed like you took a --
you escaped via a cul-de-sac.
-I went right back
into the swamp.
Yeah, no, it was exciting,
and I could write
about Washington today,
in a way,
by looking at it in 1954.
And the basic premise is
a young congressman and his wife
go down to Washington,
try to do good,
and they get swept away
in this conspiracy.
But what was fun was writing
about actual figures --
John F. Kennedy as a senator
and Joe McCarthy --
and putting them in the book,
having them be characters.
-And have you gotten
good feedback from people
who, obviously, still live
in that world today?
-There's one Republican
congressional aide
who reached out to me and said
that it seemed like
I was trying to get
some things off my chest,
which I thought was funny
because --
There is a lot of --
You know, they say
history doesn't repeat itself,
but it rhymes.
And when you read
about Joe McCarthy
and you study about
Joe McCarthy,
there's a lot of rhyming.
-Yes.
-You hear a lot of rhyming.
This guy
who was larger than life
and very popular
with the base of his party
and smeared a lot of people
and lied all the time,
and Washington
just didn't know what to do,
and reporters and members of the
Senate didn't know what to do.
-And we also look back --
I think there's a tendency
to look back on the '50s
as, like,
this really "apple pie" era
of America.
But there was -- It was --
Not maybe as much,
but it was rife with
corruption then, as well.
-Yeah. It was -- It was hard.
I mean, first of all,
if you're a white man,
it was probably pretty good.
But for everybody who wasn't
a white man, it was awful.
But then, even beyond that,
the '50s, yeah,
in pop culture, it's idyllic.
It's serene. It's benign.
But, like, in truth,
there was the Red Scare.
There was McCarthyism.
There were actual Communists
infiltrating government.
There was the atomic race.
It was horrible.
So, that's -- I thought
it would be fun to write.
Because on the surface,
you know,
it's all Sinatra
and Jack Kennedy,
but, really, underneath it all,
it's McCarthyism and real mass.
-I want to ask you about this.
Because, obviously,
you write a book.
You go out, you do press
about your book.
But because of
everything else you do,
you know I'm going to ask you
other questions.
I'm going to ask you
about your show on Sunday.
I'm gonna ask you about
other people you've interviewed.
Have you been surprised?
'Cause someone else who's doing
press right now is
President Bill Clinton.
And he seems very caught
off guard when he is also asked
about specifically
the MeToo movement.
Have you been surprised...
-Stunned.
-...at his failure
to predict that those
questions were coming?
-First of all, I know some
of the people on that team.
And I'm sure that
they tried to prepare him,
but I've been amazed
at how poorly
he's handled these questions.
I mean, a lot of them,
you could have anticipated.
The world has changed
in just the last year.
It was, I mean, I think --
Who was the Emmy --
Who was the Tonys host
a year ago?
-Kevin Spacey.
-Yeah.
-I mean, that was a year ago.
-And I thought
he should have done it again.
[ Laughter ]
I thought he was great.
-So, I mean, it's just --
The world has changed,
so you have to adapt.
And I would think he would have
had automatic answers for,
"Do you owe Monica Lewinsky
an apology?"
"What do you make of
the MeToo movement?"
"What do you make of this
individual case, Harvey
Weinstein, whoever?"
And, boy, some of the answers
have been just --
You couldn't --
If you wanted to write
the worst answer he could give,
it as almost as if --
That one he did today
about whether or not
you can grope people.
-Yeah. It's a --
-People have different rules
today about where
you're allowed to touch them
on their bodies involuntarily.
-It was -- Yeah.
It was not well thought-out.
-And then he said --
And then he ended it with,
"But, you know,
maybe I'm old-fashioned."
-Not a good way
to frame it, yeah.
I do want to ask about someone
else who had a real moment
in the MeToo movement
and was so tragic to lose,
was Anthony Bourdain.
-Yeah.
-Who was your colleague at CNN.
-I found it heartbreaking.
Did you know him well?
-I knew him. I knew him okay.
I wasn't one of his closest
friends, but I knew him okay.
And, in fact, it was through
the MeToo movement
that he and I started talking a
lot because he was so outraged.
And we had done a lot of
coverage about Harvey Weinstein
last year, and he would reach
out, and we would talk a lot.
And that's one of the things --
It's such a loss
for people who were inspired
by him for any number of ways.
His show was about
the humanity of us all.
-It really was, yeah.
-But he really had --
The side that I saw of him
that I loved was his passion,
his righteous indignation
against injustice
and against all the people
who let Harvey Weinstein
get away with it for so long.
And it's not like
there are a ton of people
who have that
righteous indignation,
so the world is much poorer
for his having left.
-Yeah. He will really be missed.
Thank you so much for
sharing that and being here.
It's always such a pleasure.
Congrats on the book.